he is so strong but so gentle he's like
an enormous muscular ellen degeneres
so sharon's water just broke are you
kidding let's go
hold up this guy knows where our
murderer is hiding
just give me two minutes along with him
i'll let him know what's gonna happen to
him if he doesn't cooperate
i'm gonna miss the birth of my child
it's a magical moment
okay okay i'll tell you everything
thank you for letting me be part of this
wonderful experience you're a terrible
person
that you're welcome thank you for coming
in today
we are here to assess your readiness for
active duty
and if all goes well i will stamp this
release form
you can go back in the field well i
think i'm ready
i am no longer fixating on my fears good
but for today let's fixate on those
fears
okay uh that sounds fun
let's begin by talking about your baby
girls and your wife
and uh what would happen to them if you
died
in the line of duty
i popped your pillow
[Music]
okay let's switch gears do a little word
association
what do you think of when i say the word
bottle liquor store
hold up gun god
how about grass marijuana
drugs gun die
cat kitten cute
calm false sense of security gun
die what are you doing
you gonna stamp my form no i just didn't
want the ink to dry out
somebody at the door hey sarge sorry
about the mess
hi cagney hi lacey hey your kids like
the same kind of cereal as me
well we just finished story time i'm
gonna kiss the girls night night
then we can get down to business all
right time for night night girls
he is so strong but so gentle he's like
an enormous muscular ellen degeneres
you know what i just want to let you
guys know that i love you girls so
so much okay so sleep tight
you know daddy will never leave you
right girls rock goodbye
gosh really makes you understand what he
went through
i'm worried about terry we can't let
anything bad happen to him
for the last time the best cop movies in
order
training day lethal weapon and fargo end
of discussion
wrong die hard is the best cop movie of
all time
one cop heroically saving the day while
everyone else stands around and watches
it's the story of my life i like turner
and hooch tom hanks
reluctant friendship with a dog that
hits me where i live
no robocop it's got everything i like
gratuitous violence
oh i thought you were listing things i
was i'm done okay let's talk bad boys
that's the perfect cop movie
mr smith looking fine a hot cup of tea
leone
come on francois truffles breathless
what terry likes foreign films
don't make me hit you again
um i'm building this dollhouse for my
girls it's their birthday tomorrow i
told my wife i'd get it done
i had the same exact one when i was a
kid
mom charles is hogging my dollhouse
grandma bought it for the both of us
you want some help big man no i can do
this
it's just driving me a little crazy
where do i fix the prince's tower boyle
where do i fix it inside of the church
no now boyle
let it brother breathe let it brother
breathe
you okay the fairy princess castle has
defeated me
i'm a grown man with man hands and a man
brain i should be able to put together a
dollhouse in less than four hours
why does it have to be so hard
this screw has three pointy sides and
nowhere to screw it in
and there's wheels what kind of
castle has wheels
look it's impossible to make you leave
but you do have to sleep
and that's an order sir this is not
necessary also can't sleep without my
whale songs
hey sergeant you know how you're really
good at um doodling
i know you think you're complimenting me
but calling them doodles
is an insult you a big fan of picasso's
doodles
sorry can you please draw a perp for me
the sketch artist is out sick and the
captain wants this done right away
he's in a bad mood is he i can never
read them
you look chipper captain you have a fun
weekend there was a small fire in my
home
i lost many photo albums of treasured
memories
i'm devastated i'm telling you he and i
have a connection
and there is something bothering him can
you help me out
great ma'am can you please describe the
perp to sergeant jeffords
i yeah he had um dark curly hair and a
neck tattoo
wait wait wait slow down uh let's start
with the eyes
were they desperate lonely did they
betray heartache
they were brown do you even want your
purse back
sergeant all of these are fine how much
longer are you gonna work on this
it's questions like that that made van
goal cut off his ear
you can't put a clock on art
ten minutes i can't believe you told him
about my book i'm sorry
terry but now dc parlov is going to read
what you wrote how cool is that
he's pretty cool right you haven't even
told me what it's about yet
well it's the story of a gorgon warrior
awesome who betrays his bloodline how
could he to marry a clown princess you
did it for love
even though their families are at war no
all right no more spoilers send it over
to me and i'm gonna stay up all night
reading it
it's only 150 pages i'm gonna stay up
all the next three nights reading it
hey gina i got that file i needed
captain holt to sign
[Music]
gina hasn't taken her eyes off her phone
in two hours first person to make her
look up wins the pot
i'm in i bet which improves someone's
manners double score
sorry guys i got this in the bag i used
to have to distract her from the phone
all the time when we were smooshing
booties
oh yeah hey girl
catch you later mid-morning dance party
she's dancing even better than normal oh
my god did you hear that george w
bush died who died
gina may never look at another real
human being again she's unbeatable
oh i don't know about that
terrence jeffords are you kidding me
change my relationship status to it's
complicated
pony up y'all whoa
it's my wife hey baby
no no no no it was a mistake my thumb
slipped it
i have to go home welcome to hey hey
it's wednesdays where it's
never the weekend be right with you are
you sure about this hacker charles
i'm not getting a strong mr robot vibe
from this place yeah that's because the
only thing pandemic loves more than
hacking computers is hacking into a big
old fried onion
oh there he is hey guys welcome to the
quarantine
help yourself to some pot stickers best
eaten win high no thanks
here are the account numbers for the
bank where the money showed up i'm in a
real hurry you think you can trace it
back to its source you questioning my
abilities
watch this what's your name terrence
vincent jeffords
wait what's happening you're getting
hacked bro that's what's happening don't
do that i'm in your home computer
you are get out i got a lot of songs by
natalie and bruglia oh i bought those
back in the 90s nope download it on
thursday
okay now watch the pandemic spread
there's a document here that looks to be
fan fiction for the show madam secretary
oh
sarge i didn't know you were a fan of
the madam the show leaves terry one more
i'm just filling in the gaps when it
comes to cheating you got to pay
attention to all the signs
during my year abroad in japan i learned
that the hard way
there was no japanese tea sock but there
was a japanese man
you want to see me sarge yeah come on in
boyle
sorry to hear about your hand thanks
makes it really hard to manipulate my
egg sac
look here's the deal i did my junior
year abroad in tokyo
and my girlfriend shiaki she broke my
heart
i stared at the paper walls for weeks
must be so nice having pimento back
i mean you shouldn't eat that sandwich
something's wrong he's acting weird er
than normal yes
he's not telling me something well you
guys did spend several months apart
maybe it's all in your head oh
[ __ ] be crazy is that what you're
saying terry what no
no i did not say that i would never say
that not cool terry
my relationship's in trouble terry loves
women
women be sane
you